Okay,
we're back live.
Hi.
I think we can ship something. If uh I
think we should be able to chip uh ship
something
up some of the issues and not get stuck
on anything silly.
Answer one set of DMs real quick. We
will get started. Hello Linky.
Oh yeah, I owe you a quick review, don't
I?
Let me go do that for you real quick.
Warms up
and we will focus on drones for the rest
of this.
Where is Alen key?
Hello. Magader
needs compiled with lemon curses.
Okay. Missed the last two days. I've
done a few things. I've only done short
streams though. I have uh a bunch of
meetings in person here. Found the
articles you posted very useful. Thank
you.
Yeah, everyone always asks me for like
advice and you know like how do I get
started and this and that. So I just I
put everything in those two articles.
Like they reference a bunch of other
stuff, but if you actually do them and
you actually like read through carefully
and follow them, you will know RL.
You got some crazy hyperparameters, my
guy.
Really only like a few crazy
hyperparameters. The rest of them are
fine.
0.1 learning rate. Holy
holy cow. Okay,
that's insane.
And then you got these crazy betas.
Froggy. Is Frogger an IP or something?
Is that why it's called Froggy?
All right. So, we've got width, height,
length, which I guess it's configurable.
Fine.
Lives crossings.
Okay. So, this doesn't super make sense
as a log, I don't think. Right. Because
like I would expect you to be logging at
the end of the game or something.
Want to risk it? Yeah, makes sense. This
I would expect this to be like logged at
the end of a game or something, right?
Like this should always be zero.
Oh, wait, never mind. Cuz you can finish
the game without losing lives. I'm dumb.
Okay, I'm dumb. That's fine.
You're good.
Okay, we have us
good.
We'll do this one last. 706.
If this is 706 lines of like actually
reasonable code, then you've gotten a
lot better.
We will see if this is like 700 lines
that should be 700 lines or 700 lines
that should be 300 lines.
700 is a pretty non-trivial project.
Oh, you were just very explicit about
the spaces. I see.
I don't
know if there's really any need
to do this lean key. Like, yeah,
technically you can do this and it might
give you a little bit of extra data
validation. I typically if I just have a
box, I just set one set of low and high
for everything. I I guess it does maybe
give you a little bit of extra
validation and it's not really going to
hurt, so it's fine.
You also probably have to do this in the
um the C script for Frogger,
but that's fine for now. Or like I said,
we could add um we could just add a
thing where you can pass custom flags
technically to the Ccript. So then you
have to remember that you need this flag
for Frogger. So it's probably better to
just like know store the flags for
environment somewhere.
All right, let's look at the main the
main thing here. So, first of all, I
would like to actually have some sort of
um
some sort of viz on the environment. I
think you posted one somewhere, right?
In dev maybe's
doing stuff. That's doing stuff every
cool.
I got to start doing more stuff myself.
Takes time doing all the meetings, you
know.
takes a lot out as well.
Kind of tough to be really locked in on
both simultaneously.
Okay, where is this frog and flinky?
Is it in here somewhere?
Nah.
Well, if you link it, it would be nice,
but I will start on this regardless.
You include
I didn't know this was a
These can't be builtins, right?
And cursor. Okay,
fine.
We have some enums
Okay, it's single agent. So having all
this inlined is fine.
You do static arrays which
I think is good
configurable.
It's a little wasteful but like I think
this is also kind of just fine.
Windows. Okay. This is
what is window
and curses thing.
I don't know what window is.
Not in here.
if this is part of the rendering, it
shouldn't be in here. I don't know what
it is.
You shouldn't need to do this. You
shouldn't need to like predeclare like
this if you just define things in a sane
order, but it's not terrible. It's just
kind of redundant.
I generally don't like to do this when I
can avoid it because like
you can forget to change the signature
of one but not the other end curses.
Okay, but then why do you have n curses
in the end? Right? If you're going to do
text rendering, fine, but like shouldn't
it be in a separate client? because that
otherwise you're going to load n curses
every time you're doing training, right?
You're going to like have n curses
objects or uncurses strrus around.
Keep reading though.
Uh this is fine. I've actually I've been
putting this stuff in this C file
lately. I think it's a little cleaner
because you don't actually need this in
theh
This is fine.
Is there any normalization here?
I would probably put all of these under
the same active check and not have all
these turn areas. But I guess there's
also the inbounds.
Not terrible.
Yeah. Yeah. The main thing here I'm
seeing is um it looks like you don't
have normalization.
There is where
they understand what this is. So
car ops
What do you think of CC code?
How bad the types are.
You're over complicating things if you
think the type declarations are bad. We
use like floats, ints, pointer, strrus.
That's it. We're not using fancy types.
The point of C is to keep things simple.
If you try to do fancy things, it will
not let you. And that is the appeal to
us
is we just do everything in the
simplest, dumbest way possible. And
everything is very, very easy when you
do it that way.
I really don't enjoy Rust. My opinions
on that are less so to do with the type
system though and more so to do with the
uh the freaking borrow checker.
Wait, what? I'm trying to understand
your observation structure here, Linky.
Just make sure it's a small subset of
what do Yeah, just don't do anything
comp like just the zen of C is that
everything is very simple, right? Gives
you very few tools. They're very simple.
As long as you don't try to do something
crazy with them, you will have a good
time.
when you try to do like more abstracted
or union types or like when you try to
do fancy stuff that you see in more
modern languages, you're not going to
have a good time. The zen of C is that
you didn't need those things anyways.
I kind of don't understand your
observations, Linky. I don't know where
if you're uh still here,
cuz like it looks like you're just going
over cars
and like arbitrarily picking some of
them to put in the observations.
And then you have
ak invert.
And then what you have here,
you make this thing
Okay, this is like a binary mask. OBS of
where stuff is,
but then you also have this stuff.
Invert.
Kinetic vertical.
I see. So you kind of just do a local
thing.
Know why you do a local thing for guess
it's smaller.
But like if you're going to do a local
thing, you didn't have to compute all of
them, right? You could have just done it
in line
Why wouldn't you just like go through
the cars, see if they're in that 5x5,
and then put them there? They are. And
it would just be like one. You'd have
like one piece of code about this length
instead of like four of them.
Three or four of them. Yeah. Four of
them.
I also don't see normalization on this
this portion here. I don't know if I
missed it, but I don't see uh
normalization on these first several ops
can make a difference.
I mean there's still some small things
here like this should be temp
good
the app.
I think this is this could be one me
set. I'm pretty sure
First five are not normed.
Probably be dropped,
if I wanted to do a windowed thing like
this, I probably would have just done
like um two tiles, I would have done
like a 5x5 by however many channels
thing. And if I wanted to do flat, I
would just take, you know, the cars
around you, sort them, sort them
probably polar coordinates or something,
or maybe by radius, I don't know, and
then just stick them in flat. Either of
those would work for an environment like
this.
Okay, I'm still seeing like basic style
things for sure that uh you could clean
up here. Like if here, watch. Look at
this. Look how silly this is.
You'll see as soon as I scroll. Okay,
look at this.
You see,
you see how like cluttered this is by
comparison as if you just made a temp
variable for that.
It's like half of the code is this one
access, right?
which makes it quite a bit harder to
read.
So there are definitely still some style
things. So you are definitely doing like
fewer of these than before. That is good
progress.
I harp on things like this because it
really does make a big difference. And
not just in like the final thing that
I'm looking at here, but it'll make a
big difference to you while you're
building things.
I wouldn't be able to keep track of what
the hell was going on if I were doing
this.
Not that complicated car moving logic.
Then you kind of like went and ignore
these types of things for this one. I
mean at least
You just trying to spawn it on like the
first valid tile. That work
kind of always going to spawn it at the
top. Now
if you see the actual environment to see
what that causes
Yeah. How would I do this, right? I
would probably just pick 10 random
positions and try like 10 times to spawn
a car or whatever.
I dropped a video in general. Let me see
what we're looking at here.
Will help.
There are roadblocks as well where I
guess there are no cars in the road
blocks.
I would have structured things a little
differently. I think
700's definitely long for this.
Okay. And now here we have the rendering
which is versus stuff which is fine.
I mean, I think you're going to have
like
you'd have something that would look a
fair bit cooler if you would do um
like actual graphics for it and it
wouldn't be any more code, but that's
fine.
Yeah. So you're doing this thing here
where like
I guess you have to draw every tile
anyways.
I'd probably just have a list or like
I'd have an array of cars everywhere,
right? It just has the cars flat with
their positions.
It probably be easier.
Maybe not. It might be harder to move
them then.
A little non-trivial, I guess.
Me think how I would actually
No, maybe I would do it the way you're
doing it here actually.
Yeah, I think that this is fine. Like
this is how I This is probably how I
would do it as a first pass as well.
Fine.
I do I don't know why you have the
Windows stuff though in uh
in the environment instead of in a
renderer. It's because you don't have
like a client strct. I think you end up
having to do everything in there which
maybe isn't bad. I guess because it
doesn't technically open up a window.
I'd have to see if n curses does any
weird initialization.
You create a lily pad path. That's
funny.
Sometimes I'm literally just like when
I'm looking at stuff like this, I just
like kind of think about what the
function is supposed to do and then I
kind of just guess in my head how much
code I think it would take and see if
that's like the amount of code that you
You don't need to put it into a client.h
link key. You don't need a separate
file, just a separate strct.
You know what? You see what I mean? I
don't necessarily know if you need it.
So with ray, you definitely need it
because you don't want ray objects in
your or ray strrus in your environment.
You don't like
It's strct level, not
I like I don't know how big that window
thing is and what it's going to do under
the hood with end curses cuz like when
you go to train, right, remember you're
going to make 8,000 of those.
Anything in the struct is going to get
repeated x8,000.
definitely extras
too.
Okay,
so
this is definitely an improvement.
Um,
the end looks good. like the actual
what's going on looks reasonable to me.
Uh I think that you can make like as for
improving
I think that you the patterns I'm seeing
are
uh not using temp variables where they
make your life easier.
Uh I'm seeing
like kind of redundant stuff. Some of
it's more forgivable because it's like,
oh yeah, okay, you can kind of just mems
set stuff. Um,
I there are definitely like blocks of
logic as well where like you could have
compressed things and done stuff in like
one pass over the data instead of three.
Really, the way that you see that part
of it is experience. The other part is
just like keeping everything clean so
it's easier to see the patterns.
the less code and the simpler stuff you
have, the easier it is to kind of see
those patterns.
I think that you're probably writing
around 30 to 50% too much code at the
moment for a problem, which is a heck of
an improvement from before.
I'm trying to think what actionable
stuff I can give you.
window takes control of your term and
get subdivided
only gets actually. Okay. So, if that
strruct if that window strct isn't huge,
it's fine
because you're going to make
Oh, yeah. It's not huge. Okay, that's
fine because it's just a pointer. That's
fine.
Yeah, I wouldn't bother with that.
That's fine.
I mean the thing is like at least now
you're you're actually like executing on
reasonably sized projects. It's just the
simplicity which will come with more
experience.
I would suggest to you as an exercise
before I merge this. You don't don't go
redo everything or don't even go redo
any substantial portion. Just like go
through and like look for a couple spots
where hey, I have this variable 40
times. I could use a temp. Hey, I have
like this redundant for loop. I could
use a mess set. I just go through and do
as an exercise just go through and like
look for a couple different places like
that and just see how much the code
cleans up just immediately from that.
And then I will merge this as is without
making you like really do a ton of
stuff. Um,
and I think the rest will come with
time. Like
it's one of those things where when
you're still relatively new, you're
thinking about the nuts and the bolts a
lot and you're kind of like not seeing
the forest for the trees, right? cuz
like I
I don't even fully necessarily
understand what your obs function is,
but like I already know that I could
make it at most 2/3 the length, probably
half the length, right?
Cuz like I just know that you don't need
this many passes over the data.
That will come with time though.
I think fixing a couple nuts and bolts
will give you a little bit more clarity
over what you're doing. And then other
than that, it's just keep putting in
reps. And uh I mean there's only like
the plus side, right, is if there's only
50% of this to shave off, I would say.
No, not 50%. 50% too much. So it's 33%
to shave off. I think you could probably
do this in about 450 500 lines while
keeping it relatively clean and not
gulped at all.
So that's the the margin if you will.
Other than that, this will be a cool
environment. So definitely thank you for
uh for code on this. We will have to
figure out something with the term
rendering because we got to put it on
the website. Don't know how that's going
to work. We might actually still need to
put a windowed view in anyways if we
want to do that. No, you don't need
enums, linky. The defines are totally
fine. Don't deal with that. The defines
are totally fine.
You don't need to mess with enums. The
pound defines are totally good.
That's not even That's like not even at
all on the list of things that I'm like
caring about looking at this.
Okay, cool. Any questions for me before
I start on uh the drone stuff?
Oh, and I forgot to answer Spencer's
question. Going through off policy
papers given DQN stores samples and a
million buffer. How much different is
that from on policy with our batch size
of 500k plus?
Uh
so Spencer I forget how their buffers
work. I don't think it's just the 1
million most recent though. In the
original DQN, it probably is, but like
in follow-up works, I don't think they
just store the the million most recent.
I got enough to work on now. Good. It
takes time. Like,
I I put out those two guides, like the
programming guide and the AI guide. I do
seriously think that becoming a good
programmer is harder than becoming a
good AI researcher. I know a ton of good
AI researchers. Most of them are
god-awful programmers.
And that doesn't mean that learning like
to be a good programmer is not valuable,
right? Most of what I do in Puffer Lib
and the way that I make my stuff work is
just by being a better programmer than
other researchers.
It just lets you solve different types
of problems, right? Like I'm not going
to be doing stuff that's mathematically
at the level of a lot of other people,
and that's fine.
It unlocks different problems that you
can solve.
Moving
to rainbow next.
DQN just stores recent. Yeah, but DQN is
a really stupid algorithm that doesn't
work, Spencer. Like you should not be
comparing DQN to PO. You should be
comparing like DQN to reinforce
like DQN is not the base algorithm. It's
this is the problem with off policy is
like in order to make it work you have
to have way more stuff bolted onto it
right than you have to have for PO like
PO is reinforced you bolt on advantage
estimation which is literally already
there it's just like a better form of it
right and then you bolt on uh the clip
factor and you just have uh you just
have PO already right you have to bolt
on six different tricks to DQN and to
make it actually work.
How to learn Marl. I don't know if I
should learn about RL or I can. It's the
exact same thing that's covered in my
guide.
Read my reinforcement learning guide
covers all of this.
That goes for everyone watching here as
well. Jesus 5341
X.
You know, these guys have done
reasonably well. They have all of my
best advice in one place. I wrote them
specifically to answer these types of
questions. They're relatively easy reads
as well. They're meant to be accessible.
Okay.
Marl's no different from single agent
RL. All the papers on Marl specific
methods are just like wrong.
Yeah, definitely read those. It will
take you a while, but like read those
very carefully. I put a lot of time into
making those like the actual best
resources to learn.
You will not find an easier starting
point in RL than that.
Well, that actually teaches you, right?
There are like tons of guides that like
are easier but don't actually teach you
anything
that fall into entertainment more than
anything.
All right.
Trying to think what we should start
with on the uh the drone swarms. I guess
I guess the first thing is going to be
just to see
But one of the things I realized that I
can do I realized this yesterday cuz I I
went to uh like just a fun meetup and SF
is kind of a weird place in the sense
that you'll go to like some random event
with some people you know and like you
know there'll be a guy from pretty much
every major lab there. Uh, but one of
the things that I realized that I can
completely legally do is if I could find
like some ex Deep Mind people with
expired NDAs. Um, I don't really think
that Deep Mind cares all that much
anyways about like the RL that they were
doing in 2017 to 2020 generally. And
like a lot of the stuff from that era, I
I would like some pointers as to like
what are the parts that actually make it
work versus like the parts that are kind
of just there to be flashy, you know?
There are definitely some parts that are
just there to be flashy.
Why Deep Mind stop working? They didn't
stop working on RL. They just do
different stuff and a lot of it involves
language models now, right?
It's actually the one place that didn't
really stop working on RL, but
I doubt that they consider anything from
like 2017 to 2020 to be particularly uh
relevant or, you know, trade secret
anymore.
The NDAs from then are all expired
anyways,
unless they're fiveyear ones, I guess. I
don't know. They're probably not.
They kind of did some cool work in that
era. It's just like the thing is that
the Open AI papers from that era were a
lot more actionable because they just
they didn't have as many moving parts,
you know, whereas the DeepMind ones like
they also got good results, but they had
way more moving parts.
You kind of don't know what to keep and
what's kind of just there.
impressive tech. Yeah,
I base a lot of my stuff more off of the
um the open AI papers at the time
because like the results were every bit
as impressive if not more so. Uh I
personally I take I don't really know
how to think about Go to be honest. That
one's tougher, but I take OpenAI 5 over
Alpha Star. And uh the methods used in
open AI5 were way simpler and it still
works.
Ah, you know, I messed I messed this up.
I forgot it's
forgot about that.
Favorite RL powered commercial product.
Um,
it's kind of just in a bunch of like
it's kind of just in a bunch of random
stuff without you really knowing it is
the thing.
I can tell you stuff I'm excited about
that we're going to be able to build
now, right? But like as for where it's
in existing commercial stuff, I have
some references in my uh my paper on
like places it's been used. But like you
should really think of RL as just having
a big but very diffuse impact, right?
How long have you worked on your coding
and RL skills? I've been programming
since I was like 12 and doing AI
research since I was 16.
Neither were very good back then, mind
you, but that's about when I started.
I'm almost surprised that it is
training. Like, it's a lot harder of a
problem here. It's not training
particularly well, it seems. Unless
Now, I already have the uh the
randomization settings correct.
Guess we don't really know for sure what
the uh the comparison is. Maybe 3.5
rings is actually good. They're like way
more spread out now, right?
Yeah, Adrian, like I actually I talked
to a bunch of companies that tell me
about like small things that they have
RL deployed in that I can't really talk
about, but it's like
it's not going to be like, hey, this
product is powered by RL, right? It's
like there's a piece of the thing that's
RL that you don't really hear about. So,
it's like diffuse but broad impact.
or like good like heavy but diffuse
impact, right? Big but diffuse.
I mean, this trains at least.
Why though?
Why?
Why is RL not the main solution? Uh
because RL has been horribly cursed and
janky until literally I just in the past
few months with Puffer Lib have made a
lot of stuff work.
Like if you go look at RL with SP3 or
RLIB or like existing tools, it doesn't
work. You need a lot of really good
people to suffer for a long time to make
it work for any specific application.
This whole business of like, hey, brand
new programmers are just coming in and
building environments and making RL
work. That did not exist before Puffer
Lip. I cannot emphasize that enough.
This is not one of those things where
I'm like overselling it and it's like,
oh yeah, Puffer Lib's a bit better, but
it's like really not that crazy. No,
this is like a monumental difference in
the field.
Like literally do anything with Puffer
Lib and then go try to do the same thing
with any other RL library or tool of
your choice and see what the difference
This
Yeah. So, this is super fun.
Oh, yeah. These guys learn perfectly.
Look at that.
Boom.
Yeah, we just trained uh we just trained
this policy in 2 minutes. Tell me this
is not sci-fi magic.
Can you tell me
what dark? Tell you what,
there's a war on Twitter about it. RL is
at its best won't get better and the
other says it's the problem. No, the war
on Twitter is I I don't know what your
Can you tell me what like I'm not sure
what your question was. Um, so the thing
with Twitter is
just ignore that. Like it's they're
talking about LLM RL that doesn't it's
not remotely comparable to the stuff
we're doing here. This stuff is
absolutely going to get better. It's
incredibly obvious that it's going to
get better and it has already gotten a
thousand times better in the last year
with like just me and my small group of
open source contributors.
That's not like, oh, Google's invested
billions of dollars and it's like kind
of not getting any better. No, it's like
a thousand times better with almost no
resources.
These guys form a cube.
They're working on it. A little tough
for them.
They're like kind of doing it right. The
formations don't seem to be quite as
good though.
I mean, they're like trying to do the
task.
Lag. Come on. Go make me an American
flag.
See if they can do it.
You somehow like
You know what though? I want to train
without randomization before concluding
that I've broken something. I think it's
quite possible that this just like it's
trickier to learn with all this
randomization and noise
cuz like they're kind of doing a flag
but it's just like they're floating
around a bunch.
see what this does.
47 and four are the numbers to beat.
There any cross environment benchmarks
you're doing to see how it generalizes
the learning?
Uh yes, but the thing is like
you don't try to zeroot a policy trained
on breakout to pong. That simply does
not work. Um it obviously does not work.
Like in principle it cannot work. You
can train a policy on multiple
environments but if you want like zeroot
transfer you're going to need hundreds
of environments. So what you can do
instead, right, is you take the
algorithms and the methods that we
develop and then you kind of just try to
train a new policy out of the box on a
different environment and you see how
well that works. And we do this
periodically, right? Like we have 25
different environments. We don't use 25
environments during our development
phase, right? We use like, you know,
three or five of them. And then uh we go
see, hey, how well does this do on all
the environments? And if we've done our
job well, then when we make an
advancement on a smaller subset, you'll
see that just out of the box, the RL
works better on everything. And that's
what's happened with Puffer 3.
and the PF is going up on the uh the
other thing here. I think this better.
And then if this can make the flag, then
we'll figure out basically what went
wrong with um warming. It's probably
just physics,
like the way that we do the
randomization. Probably make some of the
drones really fiddly to control. Fix
that.
Have you code any algorithm
in C or only the M's? There's no point
in doing the uh the training code in C.
Nobody will use it. We do have an
inference library like we can do neural
net inference in C. Uh we don't use this
during the training process but we do
use it for all of our demos on the
website. So we take the trained weights
from PyTorch, we load them into networks
in pure C and then we compile everything
to web assembly.
Like realistically, if I spend a huge
amount of time on this, I could probably
make some stuff that would be faster for
our specific use case in pure C or
whatever than in um Python. But like
there honestly there are bigger sources
of uh like overhead and issues to
resolve first. And like even if I did
that, nobody would use it, right?
Because people are always going to want
like the PyTorch front end or whatever
else.
Okay, let's see if this actually does
anything.
How long would it take to train a
similar end like this drone?
Another uh Oh,
that's a fun one. So,
usually days
instead of minutes, it's days.
Now look, if you like steal the way that
we do stuff and then you start porting
things from Puffer into that, you can do
better, right? You can get it down to
like hours. But yeah, Puffer very fast
and Puffer could be way faster as well.
Like I have not even remotely come close
to fully optimizing this stuff. We're a
thousand times faster than everyone else
in PyTorch eager mode
with like unoptimized data transfers.
And it's really not even that we did
like we did a couple kind of
sophisticated things, but it was really
just like nobody with any knowledge of
systems at all ever did anything in RL.
I guess like the code is just a
nightmare on the rest of the field. I
don't know.
Do you recommend learning C?
Yeah, C is great. I mean like
if you are a programmer or if you do any
sort of programming, you should learn C
at some point. It's really at least if
you look at the what we do with it, it's
not hard. Like everything that we're
doing here is covered in like a few
weeks worth of your first systems course
ever in undergrad. There's nothing
advanced
for whatever reason. It's like a lot of
modern programmers just never touch
anything low-level
and it's just like this crazy, oh that's
really hard. It's not. It's actually
easier because like when you try to make
stuff fast in Python or whatever, it's
just not a fun time. And no matter what
you do, it's always going to be slow.
Whereas here, you just write the
dumbest, simplest code possible, and
it's a thousandx faster,
Java Dev. Ah, Java is literally like the
worst Java is probably the worst
language ever uh to learn as a
programmer. It was my first language,
too. Java actually just poisons your
mind. It teaches you the actual worst
possible way of developing everything.
Like, I don't think I could come up with
a worse way of writing code than how
like than the best practices in Java if
I tried. It's just awful.
Hey, why aren't these guys doing the
flag thing? Huh?
They're like kind of trying,
but this should work, don't we think?
Forget to copy.
I mean, Java was basically like it blew
up because of marketing more than
anything.
It was the first mass marketed
programming language.
pretty much they just got all the
managers to think they needed Java.
you love your work and genuinely enjoy
it. A lot of the time with any job,
you're always going to have bits that
are like, yeah, you just kind of have to
do the boring thing in order to make
this work. That always sucks in
anything. But like the cool stuff that I
work on is really cool.
kind of rough. What you can do about
that?
Okay. So, let me try
go back to this swarm task.
Let's see if I've broken this.
Maybe that's the reason.
Yep. Um,
it's actually impossible to become a
good dev from Java.
It's like it doesn't matter how smart
you are. It just poisons your mind. It's
the worst way of doing anything.
Can I ask you something about my
academics? If it's remotely on topic,
sure.
does anything.
Which cool things am I working on? Well,
right now I'm working on
uh drone sims, trying to like get RL to
be able to fly drones and drone swarms.
Uh I am working on a few things in
logistics. I'm working on a few things
in finance. I am going through different
algorithm research on like how do we
improve fundamentally our capability to
learn through interaction.
Uh and then I'm also doing a whole bunch
of business side stuff looking for like
problems in industry where we can help
companies uh using our tech.
How do you code the M's and C without
engines? What libraries do you use? The
only library we really use at all is
Rayb and that's just for the rendering
so we can see what's going on.
It's just like
you just don't need the things that
you've been told that you need. If that
makes sense. Like if you just try to
solve a problem in the simplest way
possible, you'll Let me give you the
best example. Okay, I think that this
will tell you something. So when I was
taught to program, my first real
programming language was also Java. I
did this in high school. And uh they had
us do this thing called Robo Code, which
was it was this like really cool thing
where you uh you write like a basic
script to control a tank and then you
fight it against other tanks from other
people who've been coding the same
scripts, right? It's like really really
basic stuff. Uh but the Roocode project
is open source and it has hundreds of
files and tens and tens of thousands of
lines of code. Massive thing with tons
of contributors. Okay, I rebuilt like
80% of it in a day and a half
in actually you can see it right here. I
rebuilt like 80% of it in a day and a
half. We never really finished it for
RL.
Um but like you can you can like drive
these around. You can shoot, right? They
have radar and stuff. This is like I
don't know 3 to 500 lines of C with no
other libraries. Just Ray Lib for the
rendering.
Like when you see the difference of I
can build stuff in a day and a half in a
few hundred lines of dead simple code
versus tens of thousands of lines, years
of work, yada, it's just like, oh yeah,
the way that I've been taught just makes
no sense. There's no reason to ever do
anything that way. It's like tons of
code. It's slower by a factor of at
least a thousand.
Why? Right.
So that was like pretty dang eye opening
for me.
You don't believe like, oh yeah, senior
devs, right, who have been doing this
for 10 years can possibly be doing
things a thousand times wrong, but they
are like consistently across everything.
It's nuts.
I mean, the opportunity here though is
if like you're willing to rewire your
brain a little bit. You can kind of just
solve insane problems at home on your
laptop. That's the cool thing about
programming. Not true really anywhere
else. Infrastructure resources not here.
You don't
What are the B and the M there? Biotech
and then I don't know what the I don't
know MTech.
Mind you, my advice is going to always
be very specific to people, right?
My the advice that I give is not going
to be the best way to get a traditional
job. Okay, to get a traditional job, it
sucks. You kind of just have to grind
leap code a bunch.
I've never done that and I probably
could not pass like an entrylevel
interview for a job I'm vastly
overqualified for.
Bachelor's in CS. Okay.
You have a bachelor. Wait, you're doing
a bachelor's in the CS or now we go for
Mtech.
I I don't know these two things that
you're talking about. I don't know if
you're saying that you're in biotech and
are doing comp or you're in comp and
like trying to do something else or
what.
Have you talked about your setup and IDE
in other videos? It's in the article.
And actually the thing that's in the
article is it really doesn't matter that
much. Like that's not the thing that
matters.
Like literally all I have here, this is
Neovim with two plugins. It's what I
use. You can use VS Code, you can use
whatever. It doesn't matter. Doesn't
matter that much. Like there are other
things that matter way more. I've used
other like I've used actual IDE. I've
used just straight Vim with no plugins
for years. It doesn't matter.
like fixating on totally the wrong
thing.
The only thing I do suggest is if you're
a new programmer, don't use cursor.
Don't use an AI first editor. If you're
a new programmer, really, really bad
If you write 10 times too much code,
anything's going to be torture.
If you need all the refactoring tools
and things that are missing, you're
writing too much code for your problem
most of the time. I'm doing my
undergraduate in data science and AI.
I've done supervised and unsupervised
neural nets. Basic comnets do deep
learning now or what? Well, if you've
been doing neural nets and comn nets,
you've already been doing deep learning.
Um,
like so my advice, I have all of my best
advice here on X in articles because I
always get these questions, right? I
have two articles. I wrote them just for
you guys. My advice for programming in
ML
people apparently like this. This is for
honestly not even brand new programmers.
Like this just has my best general
advice overall as well as for new
programmers. Um, this also includes like
how to get good at ML a little bit. Some
of the really it includes like the
pieces that nobody tells you. And then
for RL specifically, I've got this one
endorsed by Carmarmac himself.
I got to go find a retweet for it to go
frame it or something. But uh yeah,
Carmarmac's awesome. Oh yeah, this is
good advice.
So don't trust me, trust him.
Yeah. So, I definitely broke something
here because the swarm stuff used to
just work instantly.
What are these drones doing way out
here?
It's like almost a flag, right? Almost
the flag, but then what are these guys
doing
now? Yeah, they'll take a while to read
because like
I think it's 6,000 total words. It's
like 25 pages of material, but it links
you to a bunch of other stuff along the
way.
It's still a heck of a lot easier than
anything else you're going to find,
though, like starter material.
87%
Could
Did I ever do this?
I think that if I recall, Hang on, let's
just just do the flag task real quick
just to make sure.
we retrain this
on just the flag task.
Honestly, this sort of like experimental
debug loop stuff is probably like my
least favorite part of my work. Yeah,
it's not entirely true. There's some
pretty there's some pretty jank like
engineering stuff. I enjoy a lot of the
engineering stuff a lot more.
Yeah, this sort of stuff is kind of just
like eh very carefully go through all
possible permutations of your problem.
and figure out which ones work, which
ones don't. Build up some patterns as to
why they probably do or don't work.
Repeat until solved.
Obviously, having it train in 2 minutes
is way more helpful than uh having to
wait days, cuz then what do you even do?
Okay, so this is a a big difference in
perf here.
94%. So I think that this will make us a
flag.
I don't actually know the ceiling
because the 100 in this uh is you are on
top of the target the entire time. But
obviously you don't start at the target
position, otherwise it would be trivial.
Like they have to go to the target. So
however long it takes them to get there
is the amount of time that they're not
going to be getting the maximum reward.
We'll see if this builds the American
flag.
Oh, yeah. Something's just not loading
correctly because this is um
yeah, this does not match the numbers
that we were seeing at
That does not look like 93 to me.
Not even close.
This is why I guess I should have
numerical eval as well
after training.
You don't usually run into stuff like
this at all, though.
What is it doing even?
It's just kind of floaty, right?
Oh, wait. Hang on.
No, no, no. This is fine. Yeah. No, I
have this correct.
I definitely have it correct.
Why does the drone do this?
Believe these are the same numbers.
like they curve around. It's like
floaty, right?
Like they don't handle well
I guess I could go check the uh the PF
numbers.
I should have some runs if I uh if I
look I should have some runs.
Yeah. No, I remember it being higher
than this actually.
Okay. So maybe
do we do maybe we did legitimately
T
the original here
ends
that does any right
I wouldn't think that the uh the grid
size would matter, but you never know.
technically possible that like you just
float around too much early in training.
Takes forever to learn OB and you don't
have enough time to learn the main task.
Thought it was pretty stable though.
We're I mean we're really we're looking
for
like high 90s
for a solve.
Low 90s apparently means that you get
sort of near the target and then float
around.
Should be getting strictly negative
reward for doing that is the good thing.
The last part of it they should be
getting negative reward for
Don't use LMS at all. Do you not see my
autocomplete in here?
See that? That's autocomplete, right?
It's just a uh a substantially smaller
normal language model. And it doesn't
have to be that smart because it mostly
helps me type. It doesn't uh I don't
like use it for full blocks of Good.
I also just genuinely recommend people
stay as far away from that as possible.
Like if you're just trying to build some
like really simple apps or whatever,
cool. But if you're actually trying to
get good at whatever area of
programming, whatever area of AI,
um that is not helping you get good.
that's just doing the work for you and
you you learn nothing and have no value.
Yeah. So, this leveled at exactly the
same PF as before.
So what does that tell us?
Likely there's some other variable that
I did not
anticipate in here. Definitely is not
the uh the size of map
Yeah.
Also, like
most of the models are now they're RL so
stupidly that like
interacting with LLMs in almost any way
just feels horrible to me now.
Like I'll use Grock occasionally for
docs and stuff like I don't know. I went
and I I was chatting with a bunch of
researchers yesterday and they were all
like astounded to see that I use Grock
for stuff. Like why use these other
ones? like, well, not using the LMS to
write code. Like, one is just as good as
another for looking up docs or whatever.
And frankly, you wouldn't even need them
to look up docs if like docs didn't suck
so much these days, largely because they
expect people to just use LLMs.
There absolutely are libraries where I
just never use LLMs for them at all
because they actually have better docs.
I do remember this being like somewhat
fiddly.
Our learning did not collide at all. I
guess I did probably. I changed like
some obs.
Let me see what OBS I changed.
you design a game with an RL agent. So
it' be unique for every person
would use RL
unique for every person.
I mean, that's not what my mind goes to
immediately, right?
Like, one of the obvious first
applications of this in like actual game
agents is just having cracked out enemy
AI,
the most popular games are competitive
games where basically you crowdsource
the AI, right? The opponents are people
because you can't make AI that's as good
as them.
If you actually could have like scalable
difficulty AI opponents,
that would be quite interesting.
Are you a Dota 2 player? No, I played a
little bit when um Open AAI was doing
its uh you know, Open AAI 5 to
understand the game and I've played some
League.
I don't really play any competitive
games at the moment.
You know, I kind of just play a few
chill things in my spare time.
Map coordinate project. Map coordinate
project. Oh, no. That's I didn't do the
map coordinate project. I used it in.
We do have this though.
This is based off of Dota.
So, this agent is controlled with RL.
I'm not touching it. Right. The
opponents are scripted.
Uh let's see.
Trying to evade here. Yeah, see it's
like kiting a little bit.
Got its teammates here with it. They
take first tower.
Mini version of open AI5.
Five unique characters with three
different abilities each. It's the
mirror match.
You can go play it as well if you just
like hold shift or whatever. You can
take control of the uh the agent.
Okay. Okay. So, I mean this observation
is
what I expected it to be. I didn't
break anything in the observations here.
I move that puffer.
You're a little big
What to do?
about this.
Any reason behind Puffer signature?
All the logos nowadays for AI companies
are lame.
I figured we just have a fun mascot
instead.
He's funny. He like he puffs up like an
inhale thing. So, I have like this thing
on the website where he like inhales a
whole bunch of different projects.
The project gets bigger. The puffer
puffs up.
I don't know. I guess when I was growing
up, like a lot of companies had mascots.
Now that I remember, now I remembered it
was mostly like food brands, right? But
like a lot of companies at least in that
space had mascots and like I haven't
really seen that since
seems like there's been this weird trend
to like more and more minimal and
generic logos for everything. So here
have a puffer.
I'm a little bit baffled as to what I
broke with this to be honest.
article is really good
long time. I mean, what do you expect,
right? It's like, I've been doing this
stuff for 10 years. I can condense it
down a lot, but I can only condense it
down so much, right? If I give you one
course, I give you a relatively small
stack of blog posts and papers, most of
which are not the super hard papers to
read that like don't make any sense and
uh a bunch of like incremental
difficulty projects to build. Thank you
for the article. Yeah, of course.
I can only make it so simple, right? But
I will tell you, we have we've got brand
new programmers who have come in and
started building stuff and who have
gotten to be decent.
You don't have to like go go away for
the next year to learn fundamentals,
right? You kind of can do everything at
the same time.
It's more motivating that way as well
because like you go try to do something,
right? something cool that you want to
accomplish and then you go learn the
formal material when you get stuck and
are missing a piece of understanding
rather than kind of just sitting in a
bunch of formal material like going
through stuff not really understanding
how any of it's relevant to anything you
want to do.
Much better.
Why is this so floaty?
Weird.
My dynamics are literally the same as
they've been.
Didn't mess with them at all yet.
No randomization. It's literally all
over the base.
He is good.
They mess with like the learning frames
or something.
This is the problem with being kind of
scattered and having to work on a bunch
of stuff at the same time is like I kind
of forget where I left off and I like I
don't have the full model of the problem
loaded into my head.
What's this?
Huh? They made games.
This is cool.
I mean,
yeah, you can't do it with RL, like just
straight RL because it's pattern
matching stuff.
Well, unless you could probably if you
gen enough levels get it to work. But
like I guess the point is they're not
going to let you do that.
Yeah, this is not AI complete though.
You could gen You could autogen enough
of these, I think.
Okay. So, this is still not really doing
it, huh?
So, the episode return is very low.
Hang on. That's That's a Isn't it?
Shouldn't be that low.
Some weird thing just happened with this
scale on this. Like
kind of confused. Like a really really
low scale.
Guess it's possible I could have just
messed with this somehow.
now. I would expect actually the
normalization for the grid to mess stuff
up,
but apparently that was not the case.
This does not train at all though.
This is a much better reward scale
I guess technically we could just decide
screw it, we're going to sweep
everything.
Would that be a smarter use of the time?
Like set up a sweep?
The problem is I'm not convinced that
there's not something totally wrong
here.
reset agent gets compute reward?
Okay. No, they do get their reward
computed. So, this is correct.
We do need to have a metric for um
for Perf, don't we?
here. You're training custom drone
environment using puffer lab and
pietorch.
Yes. So, this is a drone environment.
Finn and Sam wrote the initial physics
for it. I've expanded it quite a bit.
Uh, they're working on the hardware part
of it now. I wrote the original puffer
liib and then the neural nets are a
custom trainer PyTorch.
That's a good way to blend these two
metrics together.
this compute reward does have a
component, doesn't it? That'll add to
the logs.
It does.
Do this over score.
We set up a a sweep on this and just
call it
at that.
Obviously, we can run some additional
experiments in the mean.
Oh yeah,
just for now. Why not?
Yeah. So, this should start us a a
decent sweep.
We should really do some net hack stuff
at some point. It'd be so cool.
All right. So,
we have this sweep going. I think what
else we can do in the drone space. I
really just wanted to have
have one policy control
uh the drone for swarming and for racing
and that's pretty much it start with.
Let me see if we can do
because I think that they submitted me
some physics.
Fine. Okay. There's some things we can
do here for sure.
Oh, okay.
So yeah, we will be able to integrate
this. They also did linear drag. So they
did motor lag. They did linear drag.
They did the torqus damping.
Good job.
It's a whole bunch of math I would not
want to have to figure out myself.
That's not a great integration method,
but sure.
I mean, we do it anyways at the moment,
right? We just don't have it named.
Math looks less fun. Yeah. Well, I mean,
I just haven't done this in years. Like,
if you'd asked me when I was 20, I could
probably figure it out decently quickly.
Um, but I haven't done any physics in
quite a while.
We have uh two undergrads who have been
really great on that side of things.
I'm just mainly helping with the RL
figure how to like expand the sim to do
a bunch of tasks and such.
Of course, we can't integrate this while
we're sweeping, at least not on the same
box.
If I can get my other box. Can I?
If I I just like
me do that.
Uh, I could try other puffer boxes if I
want to like run some additional
experiments.
could just do it on that even though
it's like a multiGPU
Okay, this is one of our two multiGPU
boxes.
I'll use this for a little bit.
We're going to need this for um
we're going to need this for driving
sims later, but I can play with it for
now.
Over the weekend, we'll need to use
probably both of them for driving sims.
Let's go take a quick look because I did
have um I did have like an old
experiment on here that I did not check.
I believe
we can just go see real quick if uh
Oh, I didn't realize that this math
comment was you, Spencer. How's it
going?
Okay, so we did um this big neural MMO
run.
I think this is the big one, right?
It's technically soda, but it's soda by
such a small margin for being a bigger
model.
Like that looks saturated to me, right?
Where like you're not really getting any
benefit from the bigger model
paper reading day.
Yeah, it's good as long as you have
focus to actually do it. It's incredibly
incredibly boring, but you have to read
at least some papers at some point.
I'm working on trying to finalize the
drone sim stuff.
Yeah. So, there are a couple different
things
going on here, I believe.
I guess what we can do is we can try
like
just do like the racing task
and we'll get a benchmark before and
after the physics integrations, right?
Go with that.
That'd be a good thing to have done
today.
to be reasonably achievable.
Randomizations are fine.
We're going to do
base task only.
And probably speed this up by doing just
like the build ocean or whatever. Not
rebuilding the kernel. Don't need to
rebuild the kernel every time.
Okay, so first order of business, right?
Run this benchmark and then integrate
the physics if it messes up our
training.
That's working.
I have to integrate this. The code is
diverged enough that I need to do this
manually.
Not a massive deal.
Uh, why don't I have my super maven on
this.
Not
this is not env.
Yeah, I don't have my envim on here.
Oh, that's mildly annoying.
Guess it's okay for now.
Plus four
one
fix the C before I forget and mess up.
You know what? I kind of did mess this
up a little bit, didn't I?
Face mask.
I left all these alone, right?
Didn't change any of this. Yeah, that's
good.
Now, this is this is going to drive me
crazy. Um
can I just really easily put my on here?
like it's like it's like expanding um
like putting tabs in. And it's not
expanding crap like
The one obnoxious thing about Envim is
like
you typically have to install it from
source.
That's such a pain. Hey, Ren. How's it
going?
Whatever. At least I have the thing now.
Fixing my setup.
the deadlifts going.
Uh, I've been pulling
335,
but I in the warehouse I have it on like
4 in blocks or whatever at 350. So, I've
been pulling like 335 for five just in
the morning.
We're going to slowly get it up just by
doing this really stupid program, but I
can pull four plates. I think it'll
work.
I missed my four plate pull,
but I don't want to train the way that I
got uh I got to it the first time
because kind of got some minor injuries
in the process.
So, we'll see if this works any better.
Not I'm not going to mess with this for
very long. The editor is driving me
crazy on this box.
I probably could have just like added
this app
best part joining for live.
Thank you. Have questions on
deadlifting.
I mean I had uh
here. Can I find it?
I wondered if I have the uh I think I
have this on my X somewhere.
Why did it just Why did it just open
that in a totally different window? Why
is it Why does it do that?
Um,
Shaky but locked.
325. My squat's my worst or was my
worst. I can't do that now. That bad
knee.
Then there's the 410.
Not fully raw with straps.
And I do it for two.
Oh, yeah. Plus the overhead. I really
wanted to get a better uh overhead. This
is 165,
but uh I got a I hurt my shoulder, so I
can't really do much right now with it.
What kind of computer is running this
model? How you observing all drones?
Well, it depends where I'm running it.
Training is on a GPU. The inference is
so fast. You can literally run this on
your phone on the website.
The little LSTM with a couple linear
layers, not much.
D5 overhead was impressive. I was
working on getting like a substantially
better one as well. And then I didn't
even hurt my shoulder doing anything
heavy. I got distracted during a a
dumbbell press,
but I've got some like really really
good overhead press training equipment
um in Maryland that I will be back to
once I fix my shoulder.
How would this deploy IRL? We have a
couple of undergrads who are um working
on that. Actually, I sent them over a
drone. They wrote the initial physics
sim. And uh the idea here is that the
sim is very heavily randomized.
You're not just training one
configuration. You're training like a a
bunch of different possible drones. And
uh that makes it quite robust. So our
hope is that we should be able to just
throw it on the drone and have it work.
We will see how that goes in practice.
Okay. Well, it didn't link, but
whatever.
literally not. No, whatever. We'll just
deal with it.
Onboard sensor sending. No, the the
model's literally small enough we can
run it on the device.
The model's 100,000 parameters. You
could run it on a toaster.
That's kind of the cool thing with RL,
right? We make these models that are
superhuman at control and they are tiny
tiny models.
Where did my drone code go?
Got distracted a little bit.
Maybe you already answered this. What's
your plan for putting it on the
hardware?
So,
RL controller on on a crazy.
Oh, cool. So, I mean, it's
there kind of two parts to that
question, right? One is like how do you
physically send commands to the drone?
That is what I'm having uh Finn and Sam
figure out at the moment, which is I
think Yexian's also doing it as well.
Um, you think I think you just hack with
the beta FPV or whatever. There are
existing packages that sort of just do
this for existing drones. You have to do
lower level stuff if you make your own,
but no big deal. Uh the bigger question
is like how do you actually make the
model work correctly on the real
hardware? And we're mostly banking on
randomization to make that happen.
I'm just training on tons and tons of
different randomized tasks and different
like randomized drone configs and stuff.
The idea is if it can fly any drone in
simulation, it can probably fly your one
specific drone in the real world.
technique is used pretty dang
effectively in uh in many places. So,
Trying to put neural net on the
hardware. Yes,
I think we should just be able to do it.
Perception will be a little annoying
when we get to that, but we don't even
have to do that for a while to make it
useful.
We're going to be able to do cool stuff
even before we have perception.
This is going to be way better, right?
Do I not have
I don't even have
Oh, damn. I don't even have my editor on
here.
All
right, we'll do it on the other box.
I'll just fix everything on my local.
Why I like having my dockers? I never
have these stupid setup issues.
All right. Now, now we can actually do
work.
Actually do our work here.
got to be
initialization code here.
Wait explicit. You do not need this
prototype. I will
But hey, this is what I get for having
uh divergent code paths.
That bad
to manually check it this way anyways as
I'm doing this
RPM
looks okay.
We have motor thrusts.
Apparently this is
this is done differently. They give me
this line.
They give me this line
is
oh they're just doing power of RPM
instead of uh
directly converting actions to thrust
which is fine.
They just rename a thing.
Uh, and then they are going to replace
they're replacing a lot of these kelps
with new stuff, I believe.
net force works
body frame
and they've replaced it. Some of this is
just a rename
already did this.
here.
Love this paste [ __ ]
Okay,
so they've updated
the velocity formulas
and F arrow.
Ah,
They get rid of angular damping. They
get near drag.
gravity or no.
Did they get rid of gravity as
this even changed since?
Probably.
I'm being stupid here, aren't I?
What I should have done is I should have
just realized that I can just do this
whole functional.
I guess it's kind of fine because I was
sort of reviewing it,
but I think I'm going to like just have
bugs if I do it this way. Just take
these whole things
to function.
Okay.
they call explicit oiler from here. So
all we have to do for this to make this
work is they had to forward declare
this. I can just put this up and we
won't have to have that.
Here's
I think this also handles RPMs for us,
right?
Does this actually might be
This might be fine except I believe
there is a DR term.
Didn't handle
would have been like at the top or
something.
they just need float RPMs.
This Pretty
much all of the annoyances that you see
me having here are just because um I'm
not on my like my normal setup.
I'm kind of on like a scuffed setup
California just to like
try to get some stuff done while I'm
here.
like WSL term doing weird stuff plus
like Docker doing weird stuff cuz
Windows and like tons of dumb things I
don't usually have to deal with.
I'm trying to not like spend forever on
that though and just kind of work around
it best I can.
If this passes some rings, then we will
just uh fit this and we'll say, "Yay, we
integrated it.
Okay. So, this is interesting.
It's not zero, but uh
not great either.
What do we do with this bonus? What do
we do with this?
If I just do the racing task,
you don't know how this works on the
other swarm tasks yet.
Actually,
a reasonable scales. Okay. Randomized
racing task. Take two.
the fact that they have it like you only
have the exact number of moves or
whatever.
Oh no. Is it the exact number of moves?
Weird puzzle.
still not good perf.
Maybe better than before.
Let me go look at their PR. Whoops.
Look at their PR and see if um
that anything
what's happening. I am uh running a
hyper pram sweep the background. And
while I'm doing that, I'm trying to
integrate some more realistic physics
into the drone sim.
Seems like it's substantially harder to
learn at this. Trying to figure out if
that's expected or not.
Ask him.
They probably didn't try with the
randomized uh version.
So, we'll try with the exact drone that
they
used, which is this one.
Uh, this does not seem to be any better.
So, it doesn't seem to have to do
anything with the randomizations.
What are the odds that I integrated it
wrong versus the odds that um
it actually doesn't work
should be like pretty similar physics
wise, right?
Uh, something looks weird with that to
me.
I'm gonna try one because I don't think
the units are right.
One is going to be no motor lag.
definitely something weird with the new
physics.
I could technically go check out their
version to see
I go check out their version to see if
there's train somehow
RPM rates,
target rates.
work from changed
motor speeds supposed to be
I think we have to go check out their
version.
I don't know. Professionally, it's to um
advance science and tech, make some
awesome sci-fi tech, push everything
forwards.
At the moment for me that means solving
well as much as one can solve
reinforcement learning to solve
reinforcement learning
field is a mess very very powerful but
just like very underleveraged
I'm working on fixing
coming ring Sanchez. Maybe without the
depression and alcoholism.
Oh, not drones form. What did they do?
They did drone race.
I think they did drone race.
Yeah, they actually have this training.
Shoot.
I think the params are the same.
Of
course, the course is totally different
like to be a content creator.
I don't really view myself as one.
I kind of just I stream because it's
it's fun. Like, this is one sort of
small part of what I do.
That's one of the coolest things I saw.
Thank you. It kind of it's just like a
watch research done live. Sometimes
research is exciting, sometimes research
is boring, but this is the process by
which research is done.
I mean, I've got to like revert it to
the older course and stuff now, don't I?
Sort of annoying.
What I got to do?
something weird going on with the
logging.
Even help at all.
How's the score that negative?
That even makes sense for this board to
Okay.
I wonder if like somehow I just screwed
up some synchronization change and like
I have a messed up obace. Now that
always does
Okay,
get out of this box.
I'm hoping that when we watch the drone,
it's going to be obvious what's wrong
with it. I would normally do this
earlier, but there's some friction in
the current setup.
the RLC only in person.
I don't know if there's an online
portion, but the main point of the
conferences is that they are in person.
And yeah, I am presenting Puffer LIIB,
which I got to go still make the poster
for that and everything, but I am
presenting Puffer LIIB.
you go live for your presentation. No, I
don't think structurally I'm going to be
able to do that.
It's not going to be any like I don't
it's not it's just a poster session.
Like I mainly am just going to have a
poster with puffer lip. Actually, they
might even give everyone orals. I think
there's a weird thing RLC does with
orals, but um I think other than that,
like it's the main thing is just people
have posters and you can come chat about
puffer lib. It
say, "Hey, we have this library. It does
RL. It's really fast. Here, have a
puffer fish.
you went offline on Twitch.
Shouldn't have.
Oh, that's weird.
Why the heck did that happen?
Uh,
It's literally just reream randomly
dropping me for no reason.
Well, I got a notification I qualify as
affiliate. Kind of cool.
Yeah, no thanks. We're good on that.
Puffer fish very friendly.
All right. I don't know what happened
with Twitch, but it's Okay.
Uh, I shouldn't be honestly, but like
the whole set the whole setup I'm on is
just a scuffed mess. This is not my
usual setup. So,
Yeah, something just totally freaking
broke with my VN as well. I have no idea
what
Oh, maybe we are. Maybe I'm just dumb.
All right.
[Music]
Yeah, I think I've just got to nuke this
and get a new setup.
Like nothing freaking works. Like even
the tab complete on everything is broken
somehow. It's just incredibly janky and
unworkable.
All right, I'm just going to accept like
I'm not going to be able to fix this on
stream without fully updating drivers
and doing a bunch of jank stuff. Um,
yeah, it's a mess. I should have just
ordered myself a new desktop to here.
Honestly,
this machine's kind of just old and
really
I should have just
here on
I built this like many years ago this
point.
Is there anything else we can do to just
like fix this on the remote?
It's like really stupid to try to debug
stuff blind like this is the thing.
Picksiz drone.
Hang on. This literally can't have even
been built, right?
What GPU is on this? This is on um this
is a 5090
It's weird that like it trains a bit
just not a particularly well.
No,
it definitely trains a bit.
Like it's not going out of bounds.
Likewise, this is training like a little
bit but not very well, right?
41.
Yeah,
cuz I added these. It was 37 and I added
these guys in, Okay.
Let me go look and see if I like somehow
just screwed up the integration.
Oh, you know what? They have um
they have a very different DT here.
Do what this does.
Might
have to change some things.
A major
This is learning a little better, isn't
it?
Yeah, this was only at 93 before. So, I
think that with this, we're basically
matching previous PF at least, even
though that wasn't amazing with this.
See if it gets any better.
Oh,
okay. This actually does work better
to try the other task.
Yeah, that's 100% the um the flag
just based on that Perf number. It's got
to actually be doing it. I wish I could
render it to show you, but have to fix
drivers off stream for that.
Okay, though we get So, it's going to be
weird if this works, but racing doesn't,
right?
If it should be that this works and
racing works and it's just the motor lag
wasn't calibrated for uh the delta time
that I was using would be my guess.
Obviously, this is a non-randomized
drone. It's the flag task.
several more of these experiments to run
to make sure it really really works.
Hate that it tries to like open this
weird app thing
just being weird.
or are we not actually solving any
better here?
Well, that's weird, isn't it?
Now it solves the flag task which is
harder
but it doesn't solve this easier task.
Yeah,
I have no explanation for that. That's
weird.
This is kind of one of those things
where like
I kind of need to have this thing
solved, but like the correct answer is
really to improve the surrounding tools
a little bit.
That's like really bizarre that it
behaves this way though.
But we do like this. We do
face
all these swarming tasks. Believe like
85 or whatever is good here.
If it does this, then there's like
something screw with the um the racing
specifically, I think.
curve.
The star curve. Yeah. Wouldn't it be
nice if the RL curves looked like this?
The AGI
Do star the puffer if you haven't
already. It really helps us out. It's
great.
Puffers eat stars. I don't know how many
environments I can make about puffers
eating stars before people start the
repo.
Yeah, it helps a lot. I mean, if all of
my followers on X started the repo,
like, we literally would not have I'd
probably be able to do this stuff way
more, frankly, because um I wouldn't
have to spend anywhere near as much time
on like client stuff and outreach, just
because of the amount of inbound that
would get.
Okay. So, it's very weird that this is
actually this is learning the swarming
task. Well,
it's as good as anything else I've seen
on the swarming task
on the metric of PF.
But somehow the tra like the
tracing doesn't work at all.
That would seem really unlikely, right?
Like randomized agents as well.
So something must be screwed up.
Think I forget to like revert the end
size.
I wouldn't think that would hurt, but
maybe.
really don't understand how this could
not be working. Like
if I just not mess something up or
whatever,
haven't tried it with domain
randomization.
could doubt it, but it could technically
be this.
This saturates like ridiculously low,
right?
One ring
goes to the target. Is
Oh, hang on.
I think what we have to do
there might actually be an exploit here
that it's learning.
That would make sense. It could actually
be learning an exploit. Hang on.
You know what? This doesn't make any
bloody sense, does it?
Reward. It's kind of crazy if this
worked.
I could totally see something where like
the physics has changed it so that um it
actually can just like hover right at
the goal or something like that because
before it had inertia.
It's probably some dumb exploit because
there's no way that it solves the swarm
task and not this task.
It would have to be what it is.
I would be able to see this if I could
render much sooner, but like
we're kind of doing the jank setup
today.
Oh, wait. Now it can do that, can't it?
I still have like I still have it messed
up, don't I?
We'll let this train for a bit and then
I'll try the next thing. But this is not
expected to work, actually.
No wonder
going to get it to work.
Exploit detection.
Uh, I'm actually there's a studio I'm
talking to about doing that right now.
No, they can't do it. Um, yes, it is
feasible. It will just take some work.
Yeah, honestly the main bottleneck with
um all the stuff in Puffer is kind of
silly. Like the main bottleneck is just
how personally fatiguing I find um
context switching constantly with all
like the meetings and stuff.
I'm definitely not at 100% here hacking
on this.
I think it's going to generally be
better if I just do like, you know, I
stream some on this, but I mostly just
get all this the uh business side stuff
done as quickly as possible.
I'm back to just hacking on all the
research.
So far, I've had some good meetings. I
have many more planned.
give you
distance penalty
rather distance.
About to head off to bed, but we should
catch up. Thrones trip. Thanks, Sam.
I've been trying to fix um the like
joint randomized sim, but I've been
having a bunch of issues.
I will be around to uh catch up early
next week though.
Mornings Pacific should be reasonable
times. Um
UK
How often do I stream?
Well, it's a little bit off schedule
while I'm in uh California, but normally
like six days a week, Monday through
Saturday.
Sam is u one of the guys who's working
on drones with us.
Oh, isn't this going to do collisions?
This is going to do collisions, right?
according to this. This is good on Perf,
but it's not good on anything else.
So, I have the rewards specified wrong.
I'm sure
think that this is like getting very
good score.
Really weird.
Okay. So, actually this does work if I
just do it this way.
Don't add this here.
And will this be enough? No, this won't
be enough. Right.
You set target.
Try this.
It's like it's pretty dang close. It's
just there's some weird normalization
going on where it's probably it's
probably being in uh incentivized to
like not actually get to the goal like
to get very close to the goal because
it's getting very high performance in
terms of the go to goal metric but it's
not actually passing through the rings.
probably what it is. I've seen this
happen several times before. It's a very
easy mistake to make.
Take quite a while to debug if you don't
know what to look for as well. Hopefully
I do.
How do we do? Not well at all. Okay, so
this is perfect. This is horrible.
So, this is like almost certainly go to
target and sit there, right? I'd love to
be able to render this.
I'm going to do one more experiment
assuming that this is the case. If that
doesn't fix it, then I'll just like put
in the work to render it.
We do here.
Aren't the ring sequentially
deactivated?
It's that like it switches so that when
a drone gets to one ring, it it targets
the next ring, but the ring stays there.
internal state. Yeah, that's mostly how
it works. I might have to go here for a
another meeting. We'll see.
Okay. Yeah, I got to go, guys. I got a
meeting to take. I will uh I'll be back
tomorrow morning, though. Thank you for
tuning in. Uh we will get the drones
fixed. I will also fix my local setup by
then. So, start the repo. Helps the uh
feed the puffer.